Even though I walk through the valley of the shadow
of death, I will not fear for you are with me.
You are my light and my salvation.
You restore me and lead me for your glory.
I long to dwell in your house forever.
Well, good morning. My name is Mark Kellerman.
I'm the residency director here,
and it's my honor to guide us through Psalm 64 as we
continue our series in John's absence.
He's away for some much needed
and well deserved r and r with his family.
So I'd encourage you to be praying for him and for them.
But if you would please turn with me to Psalm chapter 64
as we open God's word together.
Now, as you, uh, as you're turning there,
whether you're turning on your phone or device
or flipping there in your Bible, if you need a Bible,
we have them available underneath the seats.
Um, if you need a Bible, like you actually have no Bible,
please come talk to us.
We would love to give you a Bible.
But I wanna begin by asking you a
question as you find your place.
Have you ever experienced fear in an overcoming sort of way?
Maybe in a way that you would say it was even a
bit paralyzing.
Maybe there was a doctor's report that you were anticipating
and you were afraid.
Perhaps it was financial news
and there was news that was coming that
potentially could be devastating.
Maybe you lost touch with a loved one who you were supposed
to meet up with but you haven't heard from in hours
and you don't know how to get ahold
of them or what has happened.
Maybe you've been in actual literal physical danger
and you know what that is like maybe you've been in law
enforcement, military seen combat,
and when fear can get a hold of you, it's like an icy grip
that won't let go.
I we're talking this morning about fear.
I think it's something we can all relate to.
Merriam Webster's dictionary defines fear as an unpleasant
emotion caused by the belief that someone
or something is dangerous.
It's likely to cause pain or harm or it is a threat.
So fear, sometimes it's hard to distinguish
from the threat itself,
but it is an emotion, it's a feeling, it's a state of mind,
an internal response to a sort of
external threat and danger.
It's either real or imagined.
It's physical or emotional, it's psychological.
It can even be spiritual in nature.
But fear itself can be quite crippling, can rob you
of your peace of mind, can affect the way you sleep,
how much you eat or how little
it can affect your relationships with other people.
It can affect your relationship with God himself even.
So how do you tend to respond
when fear takes hold of you?
Beyond that, not only how do you respond, how should we
respond as Christians,
Psalm 64 I think is a good guide for us in light
of these questions.
Uh, to begin with Psalm 64, as it says here in
what we call the superscription, this is, uh, part
of the original text of the Bible.
In your, in your Bible, it says Chapter 64, mine says,
hide me from the Wicked.
That's sort of a, a recent title.
It's just prompting us to know what's coming.
But then in the book of Psalms, there's a lot of, a lot
of times that this label is here
and it says something like this to the choir master
a Psalm of David.
Now that's in the original Hebrew text, as old
as the rest of the Bible.
And what that indicates is two things.
One, this is a Psalm of David either written
by him or about him.
I think likely it is both.
And it's also to the choir master.
So this is a prayer of David's, which was meant
to be sung as a song.
So keep that in mind as we read this.
David in Psalm 64, he is faced with fear.
He has an enemy.
This is a person or perhaps a group of people
that are conspiring against him,
and it leads him to God in prayer
as a response, he prays to God.
And what we find, and this is where I get the title
of my message this morning, is that we, he moves,
we watch David move from fear to faith,
and his enemies become, even his fear becomes
an opportunity for him to experience and know God better.
And I think that's the invitation of Psalm 64.
This is where we're headed this morning.
And I think that the overall effect
of Psalm 64 is, is aimed at this.
It is meant to encourage
and comfort God's people in who are faced with fear
and enemies that are beyond them.
But there's another aspect we'll see later on,
and that is that this psalm also confronts us.
And I wanna invite you to join me as we see all of this
in Psalm 64.
So if you would, in fact, I'm gonna, I just wanna read
through the entire chapter if you would follow along.
But I would invite you if you're able to please stand
with me in honor of the reading of God's word.
And please follow along as I read beginning of verse one,
hear my voice, oh God, in my complaint,
preserve my life from dread of the enemy.
Hide me from the secret plots of the wicked, from the throng
of evil doers who wet their tongues like swords
who aim bitter words like arrows, shooting from ambush,
shooting at the blameless, shooting at him suddenly
and without fear, they hold fast to their evil purpose.
They talk of laying snares secretly
thinking who can see them?
They search out injustice saying,
we have accomplished a diligent search for the inward mind
and heart of a man are deep,
but God shoots his arrow at them.
They are wounded. Suddenly they are brought to ruin
with their own tongues turned against them all
who see them will wag their heads.
Then all mankind fears, they tell what God has brought about
and ponder what he has done.
Let the righteous one rejoice in the Lord
and take refuge in him.
Let all the upright in heart exalt. Let's pray.
Almighty God, we thank you this morning for the light
of your word in Psalm 64 to us.
God, I pray that as these words wash over our minds
and enter into our hearts, I pray that you would speak them
to us by your spirit, that we would be changed
by your word, by your presence, by your power.
We pray in Jesus' mighty name. Amen. You may be seated.
So our first point here, if you're following in the outline,
is we move from fear to faith.
When you realize that God hears
you, God hears you.
Let me read it again in verse one.
Hear my voice, oh God, in my complaint,
preserve my life from dread of the enemy.
So David asks God that he would hear his voice,
and specifically David's voice comes in the form
of a complaint.
Now, there's nothing wrong with complaining to God.
In fact, most of the time we complain to other people.
So complaining to God is actually an improvement, you think.
Um, and I think, uh,
what we find here is an invitation from God in his word
to pray to God about anything and everything.
In fact, that reminds me of Philippians chapter four,
verses six to seven, which says, do not be anxious
about anything, but in everything by prayer
and supplication with thanksgiving,
let your requests be made known to God
and the peace of God which surpasses all understanding.
Meaning it doesn't depend on your circumstances,
it doesn't depend on whether you've got it
all figured out or not.
It's because God has it all figured out, right?
It's because God's circumstance supersedes all
of the other ones.
And so it's not based on our understanding.
Again, it will guard your hearts
and your minds in Christ Jesus.
One Peter five, six to seven tells us to humble ourselves
before God's mighty hand, casting all our anxiety on him.
Why? Because he cares for us.
So because God is good and because God is God and
because God is there and
because he cares for you, then we know
that there is a gracious invitation from God
to us that we would draw near to him
and that we would talk to him about anything
and everything, especially those things that concern us,
even our complaints.
So I think the truth is here,
this is a a, a fact in a reality.
If you're a believer in Christ, you've been in church
for a while, this is not news to you hopefully.
But here's the reality.
I believe more times than not,
we take this far too casually.
We need to be much more amazed by this reality
that the most important
and the most powerful being in the universe,
indeed the most important
and the most powerful person in the universe has
promised to hear you when you speak to him.
And that's something I think we can be more amazed by.
Beyond that, I think what's also happening here.
So David's complaining in, in perhaps even the current use
of that word, but I think there could be like a legal
complaint that he's bringing
before the judge of all the universe, the only one
who is righteous and just the only place he knows he will
actually be heard and actually receive total justice.
It's at the throne of God himself.
And so he brings his complaint, and this is our first point.
We move from fear to faith when we know that God hears you,
when you know that God hears you.
So our second point about moving from fear to faith
is when we understand not only that God hears you,
but also that God hides you
also, that God hides you.
I wanna read in again verse one through verse six,
and listen to the nature of David's enemies
as he describes them.
Hear my voice, oh God.
And my complaint, preserve my life from dread of the enemy.
Hide me from the secret plots of the wicked,
from the throng of evil doers
who wet their tongues like swords,
who aim bitter words like arrows,
shooting from ambush at the blameless,
shooting at him suddenly and without fear, they hold fast
to their evil purpose.
They talk of laying snares secretly
thinking who can see them?
They search out injustice saying We have
accomplished a diligent search.
I like the new living translation, which says,
we have devised the perfect plot
for the inward mind and heart of a man.
Our deep. Not only does David ask that God would hear him,
but he also asks that God would preserve his life.
He's actually concerned about his life as these people are
collaborating against him.
He asked God to hide him from the hidden ambush
of these enemies.
They were secret, they were devious, crafty and cunning.
And David, you know,
may have been a mighty warrior in and of his own right.
And he was indeed,
but he was no match for an enemy that he could not see.
And that's what David has encountered here,
and this is why he's praying.
In verse two it says, they make secret plots in verse three,
they aimed words like deadly weapons.
In verse four, they wore camouflage
and planned surprise attacks in verses five to six.
They are laying traps that were hidden and deceptive.
And, and the dangers as as David is enumerating them.
They repeat, they deepen, they amplify
and enlarge.
And David felt this paralyzing sense of fear.
He calls it dread.
I have this dread of the enemy in verse one.
And he felt needy, exposed and vulnerable.
Therefore, David is crying out to God for protection.
Do you know how that feels?
Have you ever felt in like,
like this in any way for any reason?
You know, your enemies might not be quite like David's are
Exactly, but we all have a deadly enemy.
And the Bible is very clear about this.
Jesus describes him in John 10 10
and says that he comes to steal, kill, and to destroy.
And indeed, spiritually speaking, this is the enemy
of our soul, Satan himself, and the power of sin
and darkness in the world around us.
Because you see, Satan hates God.
And how does he wage war against him?
Well, one of the ways he does is he assaults God's people.
He assaults anyone no matter
who they are in the image of God.
Because all humanity is born in the image of God made,
even though it's broken, made in the image of God.
And Satan attacks mankind
and Satan attacks those that are in Jesus Christ
as a way of attacking God.
He comes to steal, kill, and to destroy.
And he is a mighty foe.
In fact, he is beyond us the even act,
the evil actions of other people.
Like when you encounter, uh, enemies of a variety
of kinds in your life, real people,
the truth is there's a way that sin
and darkness lies behind that.
That's actually the ultimate driving force.
We read about this in Ephesians six, verse 12 says,
for we do not wrestle against flesh and blood.
I mean, you might say, hold on.
No, I actually had a fight with that guy.
Okay, so there's actual flesh and blood that's at work,
but the reality is the flesh
and blood is not the ultimate source.
The ultimate source is beyond that.
We wrestle not only against flesh and blood,
but against the rulers, against the authorities,
against the cosmic powers over this present darkness,
against the spiritual forces of evil in heavenly places.
And like it or not, you
and I are simply no match for enemies like that.
Those that are potent and hidden,
and we are no match for them.
So how do we respond?
According to Psalm 64, we respond
by hiding ourselves in God.
Let me illustrate this in a way.
Um, I don't know how many of you maybe hunters
or animal lovers, believe it
or not, there's not much difference.
Um, so, so I think about like deer
and elk, like, like these big game animals, okay?
These are very strong, uh, relatively intelligent, uh, very,
very fast at times.
Uh, highly attuned sense of, um,
ability to survive.
And, and so what happens when this kind of,
these animals can, can avoid all kinds of predators.
But what happens when the danger of bullets
and arrows begin to fly?
Well, they understand enough to put that into action
and they go looking for a place to hide.
In fact, they like refuges. We call them wildlife refuges.
Um, and so you, you think about, I we,
we moved recently from Colorado.
We live near the Rocky Mountain National Park, which is a
nature preserve of over 400 square miles.
It's over 200,000 acres
of un huntable wilderness.
And and especially during hunting season,
the elk in particular will gather there by the thousands
because they're seeking refuge, they're hiding.
These are big, strong, capable creatures,
and yet they need something larger than
themselves to protect them.
In fact, you see this picture right here, this is an,
a picture I took a few years ago,
and you notice that the guy is shooting him
with a camera and not a weapon.
Like if he was outside the park just a mile
or two away, that same guy could be shooting at him.
But he knows, and he wouldn't even be there.
He would run from people.
But in that context, they just walked through the cars
and pass the camera man.
And because they know that they are safe
when they take refuge in that environment.
So in the same way you
and I are no match
for our many enemies like David himself,
our own self-reliance, our own natural
resources are just simply not enough.
And we must take refuge in God and let him hide
and protect us like a, like a good father
who would shield his children from danger
or bullies or whatever.
We need to hide in God because we know that he loves
and receives us.
We move from fear to faith.
When we believe that God hides us, it's our third point.
You move from fear to faith.
When you see that God defends you, God not only hides you,
but he actively defends you.
We read about this in verses seven and eight,
but God shoots his arrow at them.
At these enemies they are wounded.
Suddenly they are brought to ruin
with their own tongues turned against them all
who see them will wag their heads.
Here we encounter one of the most encouraging
and reassuring phrases in the whole Bible.
Two simple words.
And I would encourage you to memorize these
and base your entire life on them.
Grammatically speaking, it's a conjunction and a noun.
The words, but, and God, right?
But God, it means except for God, these enemies,
these threats are haunting us.
They're overcoming us except for God.
We encountered this phrase a few weeks ago when
Aaron Ferguson was preaching on the doctrine of salvation.
In Ephesians chapter two, it said, you in your natural state
were broken, separated from God.
You were dead in your trespasses and sins.
But God, what did God do?
God caused you to be born again
and he brought you from death to life through Jesus Christ.
And so we were dead, but God, we were brought to life.
David's enemies were cunning, hidden, dangerous and scary.
But God knows God is there.
God is mighty.
God is good, and God defends his people.
And here David's fear begins to melt away in Psalm 64
as he contemplates the nature of God himself.
You know what happens when we get afraid
or terrified by our circumstances
or the enemies in our lives?
We, we see them. And the truth is, to some extent, we begin
to have faith in them.
We believe, excuse me, we believe
that they're able to bring their threats to pass.
But when we follow David here, we begin to see
and behold God and exert our faith in God.
And we see what God can do and what God has promised
and what God is doing, then the fear begins to melt away.
Verse seven says,
but God shoots his arrow at them.
Notice he only needs one and they are wounded.
Suddenly, David's enemies would plot hide, whisper, slander,
and lie shooting at him from ambush,
shooting suddenly and without fear.
But the Lord has set an ambush for them.
The fix is in, they make their threats.
But God has a threat of his own
and they don't even see it coming.
We read about it in verse eight.
They're brought to ruin
with their own tongues turned against them all
who see them will wag their heads.
It's like a boomerang of justice
that brings their evil deeds
and plans back upon their own heads
and it brings them to ruin and mockery.
Maybe you're familiar with the book of Esther, where, uh,
Haman, the bad guy of the story, he had built some gallows.
He was going to hang Mordecai on it.
And what happened at the end of the story,
he was the one hung.
Instead, this is a boomerang
of God's righteous justice on the wicked.
The result is that they're held in contempt.
The fear they sought to impose on others
comes down upon their own heads in mockery and ruin.
Vengeance is mine, says the Lord God Almighty.
And you move from fear to faith When you come to see
that God is the one who actively defends you.
We hear the voice of fear,
but God hears our voice in prayer, hearing, hiding
and defending us.
And the reality is the results
and the effect of this can be quite dramatic.
We read about it in the last two verses, verse nine
and 10, then all mankind fears
they tell what God has brought about
and ponder what he has done.
The let the righteous one rejoice in the Lord
and take refuge in him.
Let all the upright in heart exalt you can begin
to move from fear to faith.
We see right here when God delights you,
there are two things that are going on here
and let's take them in turn verse nine.
All mankind fears then they tell what God has brought about
and they ponder what he has done.
There's two different kinds of fear at work in this passage.
One is the crippling kind of fear that an evil adversary
or circumstance can bring.
And the other is the liberating, healing, life giving,
life altering fear of the Lord,
which proverb chapter nine tells us, is the very beginning
of wisdom itself.
Think about another analogy from the Bible.
Think about when Israel was crossing the Red Sea,
escaping from slavery in Egypt
and the army of Pharaoh was descending upon them
and God's justice fell upon that army
and destroyed them completely.
God's people were dramatically saved,
their enemies were destroyed.
And what happened? Everyone wrote songs and sang about it.
More than that, ancient Israel learned
that God was truly there
and the surrounding nations that would've been hostile
to them, all of them were put on notice.
Have you ever experienced anything like that?
I certainly don't mean that dramatic,
but I mean, have you ever, in either in your own life
or perhaps in the lives of people around you, seen
and witnessed God work in such dramatic ways
that it causes you and other people to think about God
and talk about God and begin to revere him even more?
This is the result that we see in Psalm 64.
And um, so the invitation is that we would see
and that we would behold what God has done
and that we would worship him
and that we would get to know him better.
And this brings us to the Psalms close.
Now, this is not quite my close yet,
but this is the psalmist close.
So in verse 10, we read again, let the righteous one
rejoice in the Lord and take refuge in him.
Let all the upright in heart exalt.
So David concludes with this admonition.
Rejoice in the Lord, take refuge in him
and celebrate like you mean it.
That's my definition for exalt.
So be glad in God.
Uh, Nehemiah chapter eight, verse 10 says, the joy
of the Lord, it's God's joy.
That is your actual strength.
So rejoice, be glad in him like the deer
or the elk being hunted, take refuge in him, hide in God,
and then likewise celebrate like humanity.
Let other people actually see and enter into your joy
and put it on display because it brings God glory
and it honors him for what he does
and it helps other people to see
and behold him, like the old saying goes, the best
advertising is done by satisfied customers.
But before we conclude, I, there's sort of a problem, okay?
As I read this and I'm thinking about it,
and maybe this has occurred to you as well
as you're listening to me, maybe not,
but as I, I read through this
and sought to even apply it to my own life
and I'm praying about these things, I thought, wow,
I encounter a word.
A couple of words here that, you know, on at first blush,
I don't quite know to know what to do with.
It says this in verse 10.
Let the righteous one rejoice in the Lord
and take refuge in him.
Let all who are upright in heart exalt.
So I have a question for you.
Do, are these words, righteous and upright?
Are these words that always define you as I read this,
that I know they don't always define me.
And so there's kind of a problem, right?
These are promises to righteous those that are righteous,
those that are upright in heart.
And um, so I guess that's kind of my question.
Are you, are you righteous? Are you upright in heart?
In fact, as we read the Bible,
maybe you've read Romans chapter three, verse 10.
It says, there's actually none that are righteous.
In fact, he emphasizes it by saying, no, not one.
And the claim of anyone to say that I'm upright
and hard is a bit scandalous, I think.
Um, so lemme just say this.
You know, I'm not confused about my audience here. Actually.
I know for a fact that I'm talking to a room full of people
who are broken and sinful and unrighteous,
and my fingers are all pointing back
my direction too, right?
You're looking at an example of one who is unrighteous
and not always upright in heart.
So I'm talking about us,
but I'm specifically talking about you.
Can I get an amen? Amen.
Some of you have been on the receiving end of something like
what David is talking about here, some
of his evil enemies and adversaries.
And you can really relate to Psalm 64.
And frankly, I hope all of us here, if that's you.
The reality is this is meant to comfort and encourage you.
And I pray that that is the result.
But some of you have actually in your life been those
enemies to other people.
I don't know who you are, and I'm
certainly not naming names.
Uh, I know I've done this in my life.
I have been at times an enemy to other people.
You know, there's a way in which all
of us I think can relate to that.
All of us at times are self-serving,
and we have, uh, self selfish ambition
and selfish gain in mind, and we treat people that way.
Um, we weaponize our words.
We spread rumors or lies, we gossip, slander,
malign other people sometimes, whether we mean to or not.
We spoil people's friendships, we interfere with them
and their relationship with, even with God.
We set traps for them. We're jealous and selfish.
And sometimes this happens in our families, right?
Maybe at home, sometimes it happens at, at the office, like
where you work, people you work with,
you've seen it certainly,
but then sometimes we, you're, you're the cause of it.
Perhaps it's at school.
If you're a student in the cafeteria
or in the classroom, wherever it might play out.
I mean, God forbid, I I would assume
it even happens in the church.
In fact, I've been pastoring long enough to know
that it actually does.
So, so I'm not confused about who I'm addressing.
I love you all and just as much as I love myself,
but these are words where we see what God is doing.
I think in a moment like this is holding up a mirror for us
to see ourselves really clearly because all,
because here the reality is we're not the
hero of this story.
You know, even David himself is not the hero of this story.
David is the one who is in need.
David was, there were times when David's life,
when he was the enemy, right?
And so he's calling out to God who can save him
and have mercy on him.
And I think either way, Psalm 64 provides a bit of a rebuke
and a bit of a confrontation to people like us.
And as we look into the mirror of Psalm 64, we see,
we see some of these things.
I what I hear here,
and what I want to extend to all of us here this morning is
that here we encounter a gracious invitation from God
that we would return to him in repentance.
And that that's what I want to invite you
to do this morning.
Because what we've learned here in this chapter is
that God sees,
God hears, God knows.
And when you were that enemy, you didn't get away with it
because God is the one who is the only righteous judge.
And he calls every single one of us to an account.
You need to make that right with God.
Whatever perhaps is coming into your heart
and mind, whether it's a current reality
or a distant memory, you need to make that right with God.
And you may need to go
and make that right with other people.
That's a step we often lack, but that's true.
Repentance is inconveniencing ourself to make it right
with other people as God makes it right with us.
So I would just say as we are in,
as whether you're in the middle of a, of a sin
and a crime like that, or whether it's just a distant memory
or something else, I want you to see and hear
and understand that the gospel message from Psalm 64 says
that there is a hero to this story.
And it is the Lord Jesus Christ, who is the only one
who is righteous and upright in heart.
And he suffered at the hands of his enemy on our behalf.
He was talked about, betrayed, lied about, tortured.
And indeed he was ambushed unto the point of death
for you and for me.
Amen. Amen. Yes.
And so this is what we see here,
because it's him who saves you.
It's him who forgives you.
It's him who will rescue you,
and it's Him who will change you.
The Lord takes us where he finds us,
which is good news indeed.
But he doesn't leave us that way.
He loves us too much to leave us the way that we are.
And he wants to change us
and to do so in a way that brings him honor
and glory self as we turn to him
and faith, as we repent of our sins
and we turn away from those things, we turn in faith
to God in trust, and we turn and follow Jesus.
So this is where as we begin
to kinda land the plane on this,
we we're approaching our final point.
Um, God is the hero of this story.
If you have or if you will, the invitation is to come
to him, to trust in him, to turn from your sin
and walk in his forgiveness for you.
Come and follow Jesus. God is a gracious and a willing God,
and he is willing and ready to receive every one of us.
So, um, if that doesn't excite you, frankly, I don't know
what will I know it's nine or whatever the time is, okay?
But this is good news and good news indeed.
I just wanna read it again.
'cause verse 10 reflects a dramatic reality.
If this is you, if your righteousness is in Jesus Christ,
then this applies to you.
Let the righteous one rejoice in the Lord
and take refuge in him.
Let all the upright and heart exalt in him.
And because we move from fear to faith, when we find
that God thrills, fills
and changes us, we believe that God delights you,
is what we see here in this verse.
So in the face of enemies, foes,
and fears, Psalm 64 assures us that we are heard, hid,
defended and delighted as we take refuge in God.
And here we begin to land the plane. This is my conclusion.
We move from fear to faith.
If you're following in the outline,
number five point number five is we do so.
When we believe that it is not about you,
it is ultimately all about God.
Just listen to the course of this chapter.
God hears, God hides,
God defends, God delights,
and God deserves all of the glory.
We just get all the benefits.
Verse nine, fear God and tell others what he has done
and let it change the way you think and live.
Verse 10, rejoice in the Lord and hide in him.
And then celebrate like you mean it in repentance
and faith in a way that others can see and benefit from.
Learn to pray from Psalm 64 and look to God
and faith as you do in the end.
Don't leave here today without letting God
confront and comfort you.
With these words, we hear God's sorry, we hear the voice
of fear, but God hears our voice in prayer
and we move from faith, sorry, from fear to faith
when we take refuge in him.